there is still one crucial fact the
American driver who admits she killed
Harry Dunne outside this base is still
in the United States accountable is
wrong this was about the fight to get
answer coolest back to the UK and why US
service personnel based here commit
crimes and seemingly just Lina breaking
the laws and having no repercussions
[Music]
those answers focus on answer Kunis the
wife of the US intelligence officer who
was based in Northamptonshire she then
left the UK claiming diplomatic immunity
Harry's family took their fight to the
White House and told President Trump but
they didn't want the reunion he was
offering but for her to face justice
she's now getting on with her life at
home in Virginia even though the Crown
Prosecution Service in the UK have
charged her with death by dangerous
driving both the State Department in
Washington and unsecured his legal team
have indicated that she will not be
returning to the UK willingly and so the
fight for Harry Dunn's family friends
and supporters is simply going to
continue over Christmas Harry's parents
have taken time for themselves their
first Christmas without their son it's
given us fresh fresh renewed energy I
think to be able to just come out
fighting as strong if not if not more if
we need to nobody knows how the
extradition process will end but as long
as answer coulis remains in the United
States they'll all keep this fight going
here and at other US bases on British
soil
Tom Parmenter Sky News Northamptonshire